because yeah language well if I'm saying
is is right then then yes so then well
English itself modern English has
developed not that long ago right
because no English was up to fourteen
fifteen sixteen century learn English
developing in the 16th century 17th
century English the way we know it so
that that that rights of English is
relatively much younger then
then what Chaucer spoke right so so so
right there is a notion of the fact that
we call English English can be an
illusion because there's been many
English's throughout throughout the
centuries if we focus on English has a
broader umbrella then of course it's old
but if we focus on English as we speak
it now it's really recent so even that
might not make the the right cut between
say and at least sign languages did you
mention sign languages yes yeah yeah
maybe like part of the buyers like even
the first I don't know I mean it was a
Greek yeah
the first instance that we consider this
like a different language that's right
that's right yeah so like I was
wondering if like kinda to give more
evidence that this bias could be rachel
is there any other language that we know
has emerged fairly recently
see how well Spanglish she mentioned
Spanglish right so one could see that
Spanish went even younger right yeah
yeah well actually it's changing I heard
recently that at some University on the
west coast in fact I was told that by
first Esparza she she told she told us
she me and I'm Chomsky where where an
interview with Vietnam and she gave us
some news that is that when in versity
we are going to start teaching Spanglish
as a language you know I I have to
listen to the interview again she did
tell us but I don't remember which one
read but it's the first it's a first in
the history of Spanglish you know
finally there is one university that's
that's agreed it Spanglish as a language
you know and and I think that's that's
remarkable yeah at the same time I know
because like I know there's a lot of
people who like themselves like it's
like when people speak like it's because
it's you know two languages and you're
just like you like purposely mix them
cuz I gets convenient for like I feel
like nobody would say that you know but
actually language that we made like that
so in in Canada is a language called me
chief me chief is also a mix of French
and some Algonquian language there's one
in in the in the end is called maybe a
lingua in fact even the name tells you
that it's it's a mix of the same so
right no it's called media
watch me da língua is mixed between
Spanish and Quechua you see so so and
and and maybe I lingua is now is the
language of the community you know and
actually that case is the intersection
because median in Goa was created really
Midway because you had in the valley
you had the rich colonizers the Spanish
people and in the in the top of the
mountains you had the Quechua speakers
and then in between you had these people
were in terms of the social class in the
in the as a myth in the midpoint between
the rich spaniards and the oppressed
Quechua speakers and they bless you and
they develop media lingua as a as a way
to show that they were different that
they were not exactly like the Quechua
speakers where they were not had this at
the level yet of the Spanish speakers
and they use that mixing of so at first
one could imagine that at first you know
people would say well it's on your
language right it's just that this
random mix of get to our words and in
Spanish words but now media lengua is a
language spoken by a community of of
people who at first were bilingual but
now they're the main language is Quechua
media lingua like I like I really only
combine English but when I know the
other person like feels most comfortable
yeah so I think you know say you'll be
interested to read about the history of
me an angle because I think what you're
describing in terms of that feeling that
you know both and I just means someone
who can understand both that's what's
been described by people who've looked
at so the key link we see that you
should look at is named ISM his name is
PIP
Peter more skin
okay so so look up Peter Morgan okay so
some beautiful work describing the
origins the structures of media lengua
and then and then what you have to do it
as we read that ask yourself about easy
describing what I feel now when I speak
Spanglish I don't know why deeds that
the answer is but that's what brings
comes to my mind as you describe
Spanglish I think well that's exactly
that's exactly the way this was created
because media lingua the speakers wanted
to create a new identity for them
talking about identity that didn't only
see themselves as if they were purely
Quechua speakers know where they
Europeans so they wanted to create this
middle this compromise between the two
identities and they use that mix of of
Quechua and and Spanish to create a new
badge of identity so at now I don't know
whether that is the same thing for
Spanglish but I but format you describe
it sounds interestingly reminiscent to
that story Spanish because in this video
zone
and they don't speak it but yes that is
that how these yeah me chief right so
they are they yeah so in in the history
oh yeah right right so in the so I think
the history of me chief has another
twist is that there was a gender issue I
think there was an issue of they were
honking women meeting with French French
speakers so there's another aspect
that's not that's not part of you just
English nor nor media lingua which is
the gender the gender possibly thing to
do with them know who spoke Algonquin
and you spoke French and and it was
mostly women who spoke on camera okay
guys I feel like there's certain
dialects of Spanish that in some ways
you Spanglish like that would be like
considered Spanglish with it like it's
from like the border and like like we
definitely use a lot of words that like
have English origin like parkette like
yeah like they're like yeah okay so
you're using through okay without
knowing that it was cloaca it just feels
like you're borrowing words or like
you're like more than like something
independent some things like we're like
like I only really like combined English
and Spanish when I'm speaking with
somebody who like the baseline is
English but like I kind of have to write
yeah okay so and that happen me an
interesting research project because in
this case you would be your own subjects
right so I think
that's a fascinating question that you
could ask